in a creative move by anti-coup
protesters in yangon
many pretend that their cars have broken
down in the city center
parking in the middle of streets and on
bridges an act of civil disobedience to
vent their anger
at the military for overthrowing the
government but also to make it difficult
for security forces to move around the
city as protesters gather
for another day of rallies calls for the
broken down car campaign came soon after
the internet blackout was lifted at 9 am
local time the third straight nighttime
blackout
the campaign called off late morning to
make way for this
thousands of people gathering in the
sule pagoda area of yangon right next to
city hall
the protest was announced late tuesday
after the junta spokesman said that the
military did not stage a coup
when it overthrew the civilian
government led by onsong tsuchi
adding to that news that a second charge
has been filed against su chi
the military told the public that aung
suchi would appear in court on february
17
but they changed it to get media
attention we assume that the military
has done this on purpose
so they can fire one more charge against
her this is the reason we are on the
street again
and those on the streets on tuesday in
the southern township of meow meow
faced rubber bullets and tear gas fired
by security forces
the protesters gathered to call for the
release of a detained school principal
who had been taking part in the civil
disobedience movement
since the coup on february 1st hundreds
of people have been arrested
back in yangon the punk rock band rebel
riot does more than just play music
it also fronts the organization food not
bombs
delivering hundreds of food boxes each
week to those in need
they've been busy since the coup
myanmar people are in trouble the
economy is descending into darkness
people cannot sleep at night can't even
eat and are getting threatened
but there are people across generations
older and younger
who have no fear now that is why we have
to oppose the junta
and more and more people are showing up
to show that growing opposition
but the junta appears to be ignoring
that instead further justifying its
takeover and arresting more people who
are organizing
or even just taking part in the movement
to counter
its coup scott heidler al jazeera